[Musique]
bienvenue à la séroprapions je vais vous
faire découvrir ce monde merveilleux
alors suivez-moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors ce sont des papillons exotiques ce
sont pas des papillons européens donc
ces papillons nous proviennent
directement de ferme d'élevage nous en
recevons 900 par semaine sous forme de
chrysalide et donc ces chrysalides sont
installés dans des éclosoires à papier
et le matin on peut observer par exemple
la naissance des papillons on parle de
chrysalide pour les papillons de jour et
de cocon pour les papillons de nuit donc
tout ceci ce sont des des chrysalides de
différentes espèces de papillons la
naissance d'un papillon c'est très
rapide ça dure environ 30 secondes
ensuite les papillons déploie leurs
ailes pendant environ une à deux heures
et ensuite il est foncé tout simplement
[Musique]
alors ici là on voit la un papillon qui
vient de sortir et là celui-ci il a déjà
il est déjà sorti depuis environ 10
minutes il a déjà déployé ses ailes
ici je vous présente donc les papillons
de nuit donc dans la serre on a un
éclosoir avec les cocons des papillons
de nuit et donc cela font partie des
plus grands du monde donc c'est un
attaqueuses atlas et donc ils font
environ 25 à 30 cm d'envergure ils ne
vivent pas tellement longtemps ils
vivent environ une semaine tout
simplement parce qu'ils n'ont pas de
trompe pour se nourrir donc ils vivent
très peu de temps
[Musique]
dans la serre on utilise bien entendu
aucun produit chimique sinon il y aurait
plus du tout de papillon donc on fait
appel à ce que l'on appelle de la lutte
biologique en vous baladant vous pouvez
observer des petits sachets comme comme
ceci qui sont qui sont dans les plantes
à l'intérieur vous avez des toutes
petits acariens ce petit acarien va
défendre les plantes on a aussi des
micro guêpes donc ici vous avez des ce
que l'on appelle des pubs ce sont des
des mini chrysalides on va dire ces
petites chrysalides il va sortir une
micro guêpes et ces micro gap vont aller
parasiter par exemple les pucerons en
utilisent aussi des coccinelles des
coccinelles très spécifiques ces
coccinelles vont nous débarrasser de la
cochenille des plantes on utilise
différents auxiliaires pour protéger les
plantes
[Musique]